we are turning from our various other
topics to talk about hearing today and
let's start by thinking about all the
kind of cool stuff that you can do just
by listening
okay
so just by listening you can identify
the scene that you're in and what's
going on in it like for example this
okay so you know what kind of room
you're in and roughly what's going on
just from that little bit of sound
you can localize events and people and
objects so close your eyes everyone keep
them closed
and if you just like listen to me
talking um it's really very vivid isn't
it like exactly how obvious it is where
i am
and i will refrain from the temptation
of coming up and speaking in somebody's
ears because it's just too creepy okay
you can open your eyes it's very vivid
just from listening you know where the
sound source is
you can recognize sound sources
so for example sounds like this
you know what happened there like it's a
whole vivid event just unfolded there in
a whole second and a half right
or a random series of sounds like this
it's supposed to either rain or snow
hannah is good at compromising
[Laughter]
okay anyway every one of those sounds
you immediately recognize you know
exactly what it is
okay and that's environmental sounds
things that happen outdoor speech what
is being said voices who is saying it if
you don't know the person you know if
they're male or female young or old much
like faces if you know them you'll
recognize them pretty fast
you can selectively attend to one sound
among others like if you had a little
hidden um
earphone uh that i didn't see and you
were wanted to listen to your favorite
podcast you could like listen to that
occasionally when i was getting boring
and then you could turn back and listen
to me and you could just selectively
choose which of those different audio
inputs to listen to
and we'll talk more in a moment about
this classic problem in hearing which is
known as the cocktail party effect i
guess it was named in the 50s when
cocktail parties were big
uh and it consists in the fact that when
there are multiple sound sources such as
many people talking in a room you can
kind of tune in one channel and then
tune in another channel
and you can just selectively attend to
one of many sound sources even though
those sound sources are massively
overlapping on top of each other in the
input and it's a it's a big
computational challenge as we'll talk
about shortly to do that
you can enjoy music
and you can determine what things are
made of okay so close your eyes and i'm
gonna drop things on the table don't
look i'm gonna do various things and
you're gonna identify them
okay
um
so let's see see if you can don't open
your eyes see if you can tell what's
being dropped on the table
or at least what it's made of close your
eyes that's cheating
wood exactly very good okay what is this
keep your eyes closed what is this made
of
yeah good keep your eyes closed what is
this made of
sorry
yeah okay keep your eyes closed what's
this made of
awesome okay you can open your eyes
perfect you guys are awesome i just
dropped these objects that i found from
my kitchen this morning
and you guys could tell what they're
made of that's amazing
right
okay
all of this that you guys just did
happens from
the simplest possible signal we'll talk
about what that signal is exactly in a
moment but it's just sound compression
coming through the air and it tells you
all this rich stuff about your
environment
so the question is how do we do that
and first question is how do we start to
think about how hearing works how you're
able to do all of that
and you guys know we start with
computational theory right considering
what the inputs are what the outputs are
the physics of sound
what would be involved if we tried to
code up a machine to take those audio
input and deliver the output that you
guys all just delivered with no trouble
whatsoever what cues are in the stimulus
what are the key computational
challenges and what makes those aspects
of hearing
challenging
and then after we do all that stuff at
the level of computational theory we can
of course study hearing in other ways
like studying it behaviorally what can
people do and not do what's hard what's
less hard and we can measure neural
responses so we'll talk about all of
that but let's start with a little more
on what sound is
okay so
sound is just a single univariate signal
coming into the ears we'll say more
about that in a second but it's really
really simple okay and from that you get
all this rich experience okay
and so the question is what goes on in
that magic box in the middle to enable
you to extract this kind of information
from this really simple signal
okay so let's start with what is sound
okay well sound is just a set of
longitudinal compressions and
decompressions
of the air coming from the source into
your ear okay so these waves travel from
the source to the ear in little waves of
compression where the air is just
compressed
and rarefaction where the air is spread
out
okay
okay and just to give you a sense of how
physical sound is there's a silly video
here it's a speaker in a sink with a
bunch of paint and you can just see that
the movement of the speaker normally it
makes those compressions and
rarefactions of air but if you stick
paint on it it's gonna
shove the paint up in the air too just
to show you how physical it is
um okay there's something called
schlieren photography
which is totally cool and which is a way
to visualize those compressions of the
air to show you what's inside just use
it to study aerodynamic flow
and sound well that's just another
change in air density a traveling
compression wave so schlieren
visualization along with a high speed
camera can be used to see it as well
here's a book landing on a table
the end of a towel being snapped
a firecracker
an ak-47
and of course
a clap
okay so just compressions of air
traveling from the source to your ears
that's all it is
um so natural sounds happen at lots of
different frequencies and one of the way
we describe sounds
is by looking at those frequencies
so there's an awesome website
that is here on your slides you can play
with it offline but meanwhile we're
going to play with it a little bit
right now
because it is so cool
so what we're going to do is we're going
to look at spectrograms of different
sounds
let's start with a person whistling
[Music]
okay so frequency is on this axis higher
frequencies up here lower frequencies
there and it's going by in
[Music]
time okay
so whistling is unusual in that it's
pretty much a single frequency at a time
many natural sounds are not like that so
you see not single but a small narrow
band of frequencies at a time okay okay
that's enough
okay
stop all right okay
[Music]
okay so you see how with the trombone
there were many different bands of
frequencies
in contrast this is me talking by the
way we'll talk about that in a second
um but with the whistling you saw just a
single band at a time with the trombone
it has all of these harmonics these
parallel lines of um of
multiples of frequencies
okay those are called pitched sounds
sounds that have a pitch where you could
sing back the tune
have those bands of frequencies like
that
and so that's what you see with the
trombone you see a little bit of this
with natural speech here you can see
sets of bands but mostly you see
vertical stripes
that's because i'm talking fast and
mostly what's coming out is consonants
if i slowed down
and stretched out
the vowels
you would see
more of those
harmonics okay fun and games all right
um
okay so that's what sound looks like so
everybody has to have a sense of this is
showing you the energy at each frequency
over time in response to natural speech
we'll play with this a little bit more
in a later in the lecture
okay
okay
so we did all that
we'll do some of that other stuff later
okay so now that we have some sense of
what sound is and what that input is
um
how are we going to think about how to
extract information from it well what we
want to do is think about how is it why
is it challenging to get to that from
this
okay
well there are several reasons that's
challenging
first is invariance problems much like
we've discussed in the domain of vision
and other domains already
in this class
and so the way to think about that here
is that a given sound source sounds
really different in different situations
okay so if we have different people
saying the same word that will look very
different on those spectrograms the
stimulus is actually different even
though we want to just know what word is
being said
okay and conversely
if we have the same person saying two
different words that'll look really
different and even if we want to know
just who's speaking we have to deal with
the invariance of generalizing across
those very different ways very different
sounds that they produce when they say
different things okay so those are kind
of flips of each other to recognize
voices we want invariants of the voice
with respect to the words to recognize
words we want invariants for the words
independent of the voice okay and those
are all tied up together
okay
so we need to appreciate the sameness of
those stimuli across those changes
okay here's another reason that hearing
is challenging i mentioned this briefly
um so
in normal situations it's pretty quiet
in this room there's some background
noise but not a whole lot of other noise
so it's mostly just me making the noise
in here
but in many situations there are
multiple sound sources for example
listen to this release
all right debbie whitaker sterling james
wrapping things up
okay little segment of radio there's
music and a person speaking both at once
and you had no problem
hearing what the person was saying and
knowing something about the gender and
age of that person
you recognize the voice the content of
the speech even though the music is
right on top of it okay so the music
might be like this and the speech like
that and what you hear is this with
those things right on top of each other
okay
so you need to go backwards to hear
these things even though that's all you
get
right everybody see how that's a big
challenge if you had to write the code
to take this and recover that
best of luck to you
yeah
question so how does intensity your
volume sort of come into this picture
again
um it's not really well depicted on on
these diagrams this is just showing you
the entire source so the intensity i
showed before essentially takes this and
does a fourier analysis of it so that it
gives you the energy at each of those
frequencies so you could just do a
fourier analysis on the on this and you
get a spectrogram
okay
okay
um
so the listener is usually interested in
individual sources even though they're
superimposed on other sources and that's
a real problem so this is the input they
get added together and the brain has to
pull them apart
okay
so this is a classic ill-posed problem
that means just given this and sorry
just given this
we have no way to go backwards to that
if that's all we have
because there's multiple possible
solutions
it's like saying x plus y equals 9 now
solve for x and y
okay
and whenever we're in that situation of
an ill-posed problem with multiple
multiple possible solutions only one of
which is right in any situation in the
world
the usual answer
is that we need to bring in some other
assumptions or world knowledge or
something to constrain that problem and
narrow that large usually infinite space
of possible answers down to the one
correct one
okay so this is a classic problem that
people have talked about in audition for
many decades josh mcdermott in this
department does a lot of work on it
and it you can solve it in part by
knowledge of natural sounds
um which i won't talk about in detail
here
okay one more challenge
for solving problems in audition comes
from the fact that real world sounds
including the sound of my voice right
now
have reverb so reverb means this is an
aerial view that's a person kind of hard
to see aerial view
and that's a sound source
and some of the sound comes straight
from the sound source to the person's
ears
but a lot of the sound goes and
ricochets off the walls god knows how
many times before it hits the ears
and all of those different paths of
sound are all kind of superimposed at
the ears and they arrive at different
times
making a hell of a mess of the input
sound so instead of that nice clean
straightforward input you have the input
plus a slightly delayed input a more
delayed input another delayed input all
superimposed on top of each other that's
reverb
is that clear what the problem is
so now we have this really messed up
signal that we're trying to go backwards
and understand what the input is
so i'll give you an example this is a
recording of what's known as dry speech
that means speech with no reverb sorry
question
i'm having a little total understanding
why reverb poses a problem if the
stimulus isn't changing it's just
delayed over time
yep okay it's okay and let's do a vision
example
this is a little crazy but let me just
try this suppose we had a photograph of
my face
okay and you have to recognize it okay
fine various visual algorithms can do
that but now suppose we took that
photograph and we moved it over
like 10
and we superimposed it and added them
together and then we moved it over again
and added them together and moved it
over again and add them together pretty
soon you have a blurry mess
okay and those things are all on top of
each other just as two people talking at
once are on top of each other
and so you have a real problem going
backwards that make sense
okay
okay so here's dry speech with no reverb
they ate the lemon pie father forgot the
bread
okay here's the same speech but with
lots of reverb
[Music]
okay now you can still hear it because
your auditory system knows how to solve
this problem
right but look what happens to the
spectrogram here this is time this way
frequency this way and the dark bits are
where the energy is where the power is
in the dry speech you see all these nice
vertical things
and here you see a blurry mess
okay
nonetheless you can hear it fine and
further what else could you tell from
the reverb
yeah it's like in a cathedral or
something right
so it's not just
that it causes a problem
reverb also tells us something about the
location we're in if we know how to
extract it which you guys is visual
auditory visual auditory systems do
you can see i'm a vision scientist um
okay so how to study this
there's a very beautiful paper that josh
mcdermott published a few years ago and
i'm going to try to give you the gist of
the paper without all the technical
details because i think it's just like
brilliant
so they wanted to characterize what
exactly is reverb okay and reverb is
going to vary for different sounds right
you heard the reverb in that
cathedral-like space that's very
different from the reverb in this room
which also happens it's harder to hear
because it's less obvious but you can
tell a lot about the space you're in
because the reverb properties are
different the distance to the walls are
different the reflective properties are
different
um and so there's information there so
you can characterize the nature of the
reverb in any one location by making an
instantaneous brief click sound in that
environment and recording what happens
after that and then you can collect all
the reverberant
reflections of that sound off the walls
okay so what they did is they went
around to lots of natural locations and
they played a click like this
that's it just a click
and then they recorded okay so this is
the initial click
but this is what you record in a in a
single location this all this stuff and
those are all the reverberant
reflections of that sound off the walls
make sense for one for one location
okay
so then they did that in a whole bunch
of locations
and the idea is that here is a
description of the basic problem it's
just the same thing i said before with
slightly more detail
okay so
a sound source would be something like
this this looks like a person speaking
okay
with those nice harmonic parallel bands
right like you saw when i was speaking
also like it could maybe it's a trombone
right okay um okay so that's time that's
the source that's what you want to know
this is now the impulse response
function for the location where that
sound is being played
determined by doing that click and
recording right i showed you just you do
a fourier spectrum for analysis of that
black curve in the previous slide and
you get something like this okay and
that shows you all the echoes that
happen in that sound in that location
and they're different time delays and
different intensities and frequency
dependence okay
what comes to your ear
is basically this times that
okay
so you're given this
and you have to go backwards and solve
for that
everybody see the problem
okay
so
um what what uh mcdermott and trevor
showed is that um
you know well just to state the problem
a little more clearly you're you're
interested in the source
and or the environment you might want to
know what kind of room am i if
somebody's dragging you around
blindfolded you might want to know if
you're outside or inside or in a
cathedral or a closet or what okay
um and now this should seem very
analogous to you to the problem of color
vision
remember the color the problem of color
vision we want to know the color of this
object right here okay so there's a
little purple patch here we want to know
that
but all we have is the light coming to
our eyes from that patch
and the light coming to our eyes from
the patch is a is a function not just of
the property of the object but whatever
light happens to be coming onto it and
then reflecting to our eyes
okay
and so in color vision we have one set
of tricks to try to solve that problem
and recover the actual properties of the
object even though it's totally
confounded in the input with the
properties of the incident light this is
this is extremely analogous we're trying
to solve for what is the sound source
and we have to deal with this problem
that is completely confounded with the
reverberation of the room it's in does
everybody see that analogy they're both
classic ill-posed problems
in perception
okay
so here's another way of putting it
we're given that and we want to solve
for at least one of these ideally both
of those
and you can't do that with just this
so we need to make assumptions about the
room and what treyer and mcdermott
showed is that first they measured those
impulse response functions in natural
environments to characterize reverb in
different environments
and they found that there's some
systematic properties of reverb having
to do with the decay function as a
function of frequency and those
systematic properties are preserved
across different environments
okay and then they showed
um that
your auditory system knows about the way
reverb works
in the sense that if you make up a
different
um non-physical reverb property and you
play it to people it sounds weird number
one
and two they can't recover the sound
source
and what that means is built into your
auditory system is knowledge of the
physics of sound and in particular about
the particulars of the decay function of
reverb such that you can use that
knowledge of how reverb works in general
to undo this problem and constrain this
problem and solve for the sound source
okay i didn't give you all the details
but i want you to get the gist is that
do you get the kind of idea
um
okay
um
okay
but that's that's as i said that's only
true for reverb that has the pro the
reverb properties of real world sound if
you make up fake reverb it doesn't work
and people can't solve this problem that
tells you they're using their knowledge
it doesn't tell us whether that
knowledge is built in innately or
whether they learned it or what okay
okay
uh all right good so in other words we
solve the ill pose problem
of recovering the sound source despite
reverb by building a knowledge of the
physics of the world into our auditory
system and using it to constrain the ill
post problem
okay
so we just said why is this
computationally challenging um
invariance problems appreciating the
sameness of a voice across different
words appreciating the sameness of a
word across different voices okay
separating multiple sound sources that
come in simultaneously and are just
massively superimposed on the input the
cocktail party problem
also ill-posed
and the reverb problem okay so everybody
see how these are three really big
challenges for audition yeah so it was
uh brain imaging as well like a part of
the vector nope
nope nope one could do that and ask
questions about where that solved in the
brain but the beauty of that study is
that in a way who cares where it's
solved i mean it's kind of interesting
but
it's such a beautiful story already just
from actually a big part of their study
was measuring reverb nobody had done it
before they sent people out with
speakers and recording devices
and um little random timers on their
iphones and at random times how did this
go oh yeah they had people have to mark
the location they were in using their
iphone gps
and then that's right they didn't send
people out with recording devices too
hard and so then they sampled what kind
of places do people hang out in
and then they went back with their
impulse sound source and the recording
device and they measured that impulse
response function in lots and lots of
different natural sounds in order to
characterize
what is the nature of reverb in the
world nobody had done that before so
that's why i tell you this is it to me
it's just one of those beautiful
examples of computational theory
no measurement in the brain
a big part of the study was just
characterizing the physics of sound
and then some psychophysics to say
actually do people use that knowledge of
how reverb works in the world and yes
they do
okay
okay so i've been talking about hearing
in general but let's talk about one of
the most interesting
examples of hearing the one you're doing
right now speech perception
okay
so what do speech sounds look like you
saw a few of them briefly before
here are a few spectra so just to remind
you each one of these things has time
going along the x-axis frequency here
and the color
shows you the intensity of energy at
that frequency band okay so this is a
person saying hot and hat and hit and
head
okay
that's the same person saying these four
things
a person with a high pitched voice and
here's a person with a slightly lower
pitched voice saying the same things
okay
okay so what do we notice here
well first of all
we see that vowels have regularly spaced
harmonics that's the red stripes this is
a vowel sound right there see those
perfectly regularly
um spaced harmonics that makes a pitchy
sound right so voices are pitchy
you may not think that there's a pitch
to my voice right now because i'm
talking not singing but there is a pitch
right and and you use that actually in
the intonation of speech as you guys
read about
uh in the assigned reading for for
yesterday
okay so each of these things with the
stacked harmonics is a vowel sound okay
it's got a pitch and it lasts over a
chunk of time
and the consonants are these kind of
muckier things that happen before and
after and consonants don't have pitch
they don't have harmonics they have kind
of muck
okay
okay
so there are certain banned people who
study speech spend a lot of time staring
at these things and characterizing them
and they like to talk about bands of
frequency
of power
and so this band down here that's
present in all of these
um
speech sounds here is called a formant
it's just a chunk of the frequency
spectrum okay that you hear with speech
okay
um okay so that's a formant
um
and some of those frequency bands or
formants
are particularly diagnostic for
different vowels okay so if you look in
this range here only in that mid-range
here only for hat and a little bit for e
sound do you get uh energy in that
frequency band not for hot or hit
okay and that's true both for the high
pitched voice and the low pitched voice
this frequency band here is really
diagnostic to which of those vowels
you're hearing
okay
um
okay so
uh we're going to play with that
spectrogram again
a little bit more all those i now
have learned avoidance
okay
um
okay so
this is me speaking again
okay as you saw before
so i'm going to say an a
an e
an i
look how different that one is o
and u and there's lots of other vowels
okay do you see how that energy moves
around for the different vowels
okay
um
now
as i said before
if i do a long vowel like the
it makes a big long bunch of um
harmonics
but a lot of the time they're just these
vertical lines
okay the vertical lines are consonants
right if i don't say a vowel you just
see like a vertical line that's not
quite a vertical line they're different
from each other in ways you can tell
right
um
so
the consonants are those bands of energy
that go vertically
and the vowels are the big long harmonic
structures that stretch between them
okay
um now i'm not sure you'll be able to do
this i'm going to need a volunteer in a
second and i'm going to pick on ayadun
because he's most accessible right there
so come on up here you know it won't be
horrible or embarrassing
um
um okay so you can stand here for a
second i'm gonna i'm gonna say baz and
paz and i'll tell you tell you in a
moment what to say i'm not sure this is
gonna work i tried it before
we're gonna look at two different
formants when i say
ba
i'm actually going to do it rising ba
okay so there's two different formats
here and here with both of those i'm
going to do it again and there's just a
tiny little difference between a ba and
a paw and it has to do with the interval
between the consonant which is the first
vertical thing and the vowel which is
the horizontal stuff so let's see if we
can see it again here we go
do you see how the paw starts earlier
there and the ba is slightly delayed
i'll show you diagrams that show you
more clearly okay great don't go away um
okay so we're going to do the cocktail
party thing if the recording device is
here um
what is this okay this is just some
boring administrative thing you can just
read for it's just i actually brought it
to crumple and make a crumbling sound
but we'll do that afterwards
right now
you will read from that and i will
recite something boring and we'll just
do it simultaneously so just focus on
what you're doing and everybody watch
you can see my voice here and let's see
what happens
when we're um both talking at once okay
here we go
four score and seven years ago
oh geez i forget how it goes after that
so i'll just have to make up some other
random garbage right
okay review the students course nine
four all right that's great
that's great that's great don't go away
um i don't know if you could tell that
it got muckier when we were both talking
um maybe maybe it's mucky enough with me
talking fast to begin with let's try a
few other things let's have me say words
and you say words and let's see how
different they look okay
um so i'm gonna say um
uh mousetrap
mousetrap
you can see some similarity there can't
you let's do it again
mouse trap
mousetrap
okay that's good it's funny i see more
low frequency band here i'm sure your
voice is lower than mine pitch pitch
pitch interestingly isn't just about how
low the energy goes it's a interesting
complicated property of the uh lowest
common denominator of that whole
frequency stack so i'm not going to do
pitch it's complicated
um
okay what else do we want to do let's
try
let's try some bars and paws okay
let's stick them on the fronts of words
maybe that'll work better
pat
bat
pat bat oh i could see the commonality
there could you guys see that
let's do it again
pat
bat
pat
bat
oh yours look more similar
all right anyway thank you that's good
that's all i need um just to show you
how hard this is and how there's
variability across speakers saying the
same thing
um and very very subtle differences
between sounds that sound totally
different to us
okay
so
back to
lecture
okay so you saw the harmonics those red
stripes during the vowels
you notice that the um
blah blah blah i showed the consonants
and the bars and pos okay so here's a
diagram sorry this is very abstracted
away from those spectrograms which are
messy as you can see
the idea is that you're um that a
consonant vowel sound a single symbol
syllable like ba or pa
um this is time this way has this big
long formant which is a band of energy
that's the vowel the ah sound and it's
these transitions that happen just
before that that make the difference for
different consonants
okay and in particular
the difference between a ba and a pa
this is a ba that's a pa
the difference we were looking for that
didn't show up that clearly but you can
try it at home maybe you can get it
clearer than i just got it now
has to do with that transition onto the
first format so
with a ba
the transitions happen in parallel and
with a paw
this transition happens before that
lower formant so that tiny little it's a
65 millisecond delay
in the case of paw that you don't have
in the case of ba is how you tell that
difference okay it's very very subtle
all right
okay
so there's lots of different kinds of
phonemes uh we've been talking about
vowels and consonants
um each vowel or consonant sound is is
called a phoneme
if that uh if a distinction in that
sound makes the difference between two
different words in your language
okay and that means that what counts as
a phoneme in in one language may not be
a phoneme in another language because it
won't make a distinction between
different words
okay so many of the phonemes are shared
across languages but not all
we've talked about r and l that aren't
distinguished in japan and two different
d sounds that sound the same to me that
are distinguished in hindi and lots of
others okay and so those are just
variations across natural languages on
which of those phonemes which of those
sounds are used to discriminate
different words and hence count as
phonemes in that language
so there's some
particularly awesome phonemes
that use a particular kind of consonant
known as a click consonant and these are
common in some southern african
languages
and a year ago i was traveling in
mozambique
which is just hit by a devastating flood
it's really awful but anyway i was there
visiting a game park seeing all kinds of
animals um and um
i met um this guy test
and he's amazing i mean his knowledge of
the natural history was mind-blowing but
he also speaks i think six different
languages fluently
one of which is cosa or as he would say
kosa or something like that you'll hear
him say it in a moment and so he was
illustrating click languages and i'll
play this for you in a second
and he says there's a sentence in cosa
which is a little bit crazy but it has
all the different clicks and it means
basically the skunk was rolling and
accidentally got cut by the throat
doesn't mean a whole lot but listen to
test saying the sentence first in
english and then in cosa
the phrase in english it says his [ __ ]
was rolling in that statement he got
caught by the drug
in
in tulsa
isn't that awesome i think we just have
to crank it up a little bit and hear him
again
the phrase in english it says this count
was rolling and externally called cut by
the drug
in uh in tulsa
or
okay for the most part we don't have
click consonants in english
that count as phonemes in the sense of
distinguishing different words
but we do have click consonants that we
use in other domains anybody know what
we use click consonants for
there's two at least two
know any click consonants
yeah what
like what
yes
yes but that's a regular consonant it's
not it's actually not a click it's just
a it's just a regular consonant
well one is when you go
the scolding sound
okay it's not a phoneme it's not a word
but it has a very particular meaning
okay another one is how you um get a
horse to giddy up
right so those are the click consonants
we have in english they're not phonemes
but we have them okay and he's got a
whole lot more
okay that was just for fun
um okay so why is speech perception
challenging
well one is the essence of it is that a
given speech sound is highly variable
one way it's variable is that when you
speak at different rates all the
frequencies go up and down in haywire
making them very different across
different talking rates
another
is the context so a given phoneme like a
ba or a pa sound or a vowel
sounds totally different depending on
what phonemes come before and after it
they're not like little punctate one at
a time things they all overlap and
affect each other in a big mess
and the third is one we've already
mentioned which is the big differences
across speakers in the language okay so
the um you have to recognize a ba sound
um even though it sounds quite different
when spoken by different speakers
okay
so all of these things make it very
computationally challenging to
understand speech here's a here's an
illustration of that talker variability
okay so what's shown here is not a whole
spectrogram but just the intensity of
the first formant and the second formant
okay those bands of energy that i showed
you in the spectrogram and so
each dot here
is a different person pronouncing a
vowel
okay and each color this is one vowel
here in green in that green ellipse with
lots of different people saying that
vowel
okay here's another vowel up here in red
with lots of different people saying
that vowel
um
and um and what you see is
they're really overlapping
so that means you can't just go from the
energy at those two formants a point in
that space and know what the vowel is
what if you were right there well then
it could be any of four different vowels
right
so that's the problem of talker
variability illustrated with vowels that
make sense
okay
um i think i just said all of this blah
blah blah another classic ill-posed
problem in perception you're given a
point in the space how do you tell which
vowel it is
okay
so one way we solve that is that we
learn each other's voices
and we know
how a given person pronounces a given
set of vowels or words and we use that
to constrain what they're saying
have you ever noticed especially if you
meet somebody new well actually you just
experienced this with tess
when he first speaks his english is
beautiful but he's from zimbabwe and he
has kind of a zimbabwe british type
accent and at first it's hard to
understand what he's saying did you all
experience that briefly i mean that's
why i put the text on the slide so you
would get used to his english and
understand it if i hadn't you probably
wouldn't have understood that sentence
he spoke first that's because we don't
know his voice yet
but did you notice after even just a few
words you start to like tune right in
and you can understand him
so learning about an individual's voice
helps you pull apart the properties of
the voice and unconfound them from the
sound so you can understand what that
person is saying
okay
um so that's part of how we solve this
ill pose problem
okay and so evidence that we do that
is that if you have people
listen to
voices they don't know or voices that
are changing from word to word it's much
harder to understand speech so you
imagine you took the sentence i'm saying
right now and you spliced in a different
person saying each word actually i
should make that demo
what do you guys send me an email make
that demo
of different person speaking each word
in a sentence it'd be really hard to
understand right because you wouldn't
have been able to fix okay this was
property of the voice now we can kind of
separate that from everything else
because the voice will be changing on
each word it'll be a mess right
okay so that's one problem
um so turns out um that the opposite is
true as well
and that is your ability
to recognize somebody's voice
is a function of what you know about
that language
okay so you can recognize voices better
in a language you know
than a language you don't
because you're doing the opposite you're
using knowledge of the language and its
speech properties
that you already know
to constrain the problem of figuring out
who is this person's voice so does
everybody get this these two things are
affecting each other the speaker and
what's being said
and they're because they're so
confounded massively confounded in the
stimulus right
to solve that the more you know about
the speaker the better you can
understand what's being said and the
more you know about the language and its
properties the more you can recognize
the voice
okay each one is a source of information
about one of those two confounded
variables
okay
um and so people have shown that uh
psychophysically
and i think i have time to do this
here's a kind of cool corollary of this
and that is
um it's commonly thought that dyslexia
is most fundamentally a problem of
auditory speech perception not a visual
problem there may also be a bit of a
visual problem but it's thought that at
core it's a problem of auditory speech
perception
okay
so if that's true
then you might think that this ability
to use knowledge of the language and its
sounds to constrain voice recognition
would be reduced in people with dyslexia
because they are less good at processing
speech sounds
and it turns out that's true
so here's a beautiful study from
gabrielli lab a few years ago
so first look at the bars in blue
so this is accuracy at voice recognition
which person is speaking
okay and this is native english speakers
who don't speak chinese they are much
more accurate recognizing who's speaking
when they're speaking english than when
they're speaking chinese
okay
so that's kind of cool that shows you
the way in which you use knowledge of
the language to constrain recognition of
the voice
but now look what happens in the
dyslexics
no effect
exactly as they predicted given that
dyslexics have a problem with speech
perception they're apparently not able
to use that knowledge of the
phonemes of the language to constrain
the problem of voice recognition they're
just as bad at voice recognition
sorry they're no better at voice
recognition
in their native language than in a
foreign language
they can't use that knowledge to
constrain voice recognition does that
make sense
yeah i love that study
okay
so
we haven't done any brain stuff so far
we're just thinking about the problem of
hearing and speech perception and what
we know from behavior and we've learned
a lot already but we'll learn more by
looking at the brain and the meat and
all that so uh let's start with the ear
again remember compressions of um
of air come into the ear they travel
through the ear canal
they hit the tympanic membrane they go
through a whole series of trans
transducers these three little ear bones
here that connect to this snail-shaped
thing which is called the cochlea
okay cochlea is really important you
should remember that word it's the place
where you transduce
um incoming sound into neural impulses
okay right way in there okay um and the
cochlea is really cool
um
it has it's this you know as i said the
snail-shaped thing
and there are nerve endings all the way
along this thing
and because of the physics of the
cochlea
there are different resonant frequencies
at different parts of this snail
so basically
at the um
okay so here are some low frequency
sound waves this is a cochlea stretched
out with the base and the apex this is
the base that's the apex and what you
see is the low frequencies make some um
have some pic have transduced some
energy at the base of the cochlea
and also at the apex
okay
but midway range frequencies and high
frequencies do nothing at the apex this
business
only there's only physical fluctuations
happening up here for low frequency
sounds okay so there's little nerve
endings here that detect those
fluctuations up there and send those
signals up into the brain
okay through the auditory nerve and so
um in the um in the middle i don't know
here or something you have sensitivity
to mid-range frequencies not um uh high
or low and at the base it's sensitive
more to high frequencies than mid or low
okay does everybody get that so
basically the cochlea is doing a fourier
transform on the acoustic signal
right it's taking these compressions of
of um of air
and it's just saying let's separate
those out into different frequencies
just with this physical device
it's like a physical fourier transform
that's saying okay let's just physically
separate the energy at each frequency
range along the length of the cochlea
does that make sense
okay and then once you get different
parts of the cochlea that are sensitive
to different frequencies oscillating to
different degrees
then you stick some nerve cells there to
pick up those oscillations
go up the auditory nerve and travel into
the brain
everybody have a gist of how this works
okay
okay
so that's cool but now let's go up to
the brain okay so now this is a view
like this
um and so here are the cochlea i guess
that's the pleural on each side ears ear
canal cochlea okay
and the first thing to know which is
important
is that the path between the cochlea
and the first step up in the cortex is
much more complicated in hearing than it
is in vision
okay look at all these nuclei deep down
in the basement of the brain
in contrast envision
how many synapses do you have to make
between the retina and primary visual
cortex
sorry
one synapse right oh i was thinking yeah
two yeah yeah that's right so retinal
ganglion cells send their axons straight
into the lgn and the thalamus make a
synapse and then those lgn neurons go
straight up to primary visual cortex
just one stop on the way
look at all the stops on the way here
yeah
okay so audition is a really different
beast from hearing in many ways next
time we'll talk about how
audition not these parts of it but after
you get up to the cortex
audition um
we in my lab and a few other labs are
really starting to suspect is profoundly
different in humans from any non-human
animal okay
and i think that's for very interesting
reasons but this part is pretty similar
in animals just getting information up
to the cortex and
audition is already very different from
vision just in the number of relays
going up to the brain
so
those structures down there do all kinds
of awesome things and last year i talked
at great length about how we detect the
locations of sounds it's absolutely
beautiful work and elegant and fun but i
decided that was a little too much uh
behavior we should get onto the brain
but i recommend 935 if you want to learn
more about audition awesome course right
did you take it really awesome course
yeah exactly and so you'll learn more
about all that stuff okay
so instead we will just skip all that
and go straight up to cortex okay
so the first place that auditory
information hits the cortex coming up
from the cochlea
is primary auditory cortex just like the
first place visual information comes
hits the cortex coming up in the eyes is
primary visual cortex
okay
so you can see in here that in a
cross-sectional view like that
this is primary auditory cortex it's in
that sulcus right there
that's kind of a drag because when we
get occasional opportunities to test
patients who have grids of electrodes on
the surface of their brain
the grids don't usually go in there and
we can't see primary auditory cortex
right
although there are new methods where
they stick depth electrodes which is
surprisingly apparently better on the
patients and right now your ta dana
bovinger is over at children's hospital
uh recording from a 19 year old who has
bad epilepsy and who has electrodes
depth electrodes in his brain and he's
listening to all kinds of sounds and
she's recording this neural activity
with depth electrodes
and so we are hopeful
one that we can find some information
that will be relevant to the
neurosurgeons i don't know about that
but two
that we'll get some information from
those deep structures that you can't
usually see when you have just grid
sitting on the surface okay
okay
so back to functional mri
so this is primary auditory cortex it's
quite stylized let me remind you where
you are this is an inflated view of the
right hemisphere back of the head front
of the head temporal lobe
all funny looking because it's been
mathematically unfolded so you can see
stuff in the sulcus where i just showed
you primary auditory cortex is in the
sulcus but we've inflated it so you can
see it
and so this is primary auditory cortex
this whole thing here
and it shows you a property we've talked
about before it's got a map
but the map in primary auditory cortex
is not a map of space like it is in the
retina for visual information it's a map
of frequency
okay and that makes sense because the
input transducer is a cochlea which
already physically creates a map of
frequency and so that gets traveled
through all those intermediate stages
down in the basement and it comes up to
the brain and makes a map of of
frequency space
so what this means actually so here's
sensitivity to different frequencies
and so the classic structure of primary
auditory cortex in humans
is high low high high frequencies low
frequencies high frequencies in that
like v-shaped pattern okay
so this is a right hemisphere this is
the left hemisphere that's been mirror
flipped so you can compare them directly
and you can see this highly stereotyped
pattern of high low high that's a
tonotopic map everybody clear on what a
tonatopic map is
and we've just you know discretized it
into two chunks but it's actually a
gradient of high to low to high right
which you can kind of see by those
intermediate colors in there yeah
yeah
um well everything in the brain
rearranges everything in the input in
multiple ways right so we didn't talk
about this but in visual cortex you have
i don't know what the latest count is at
least 10 probably more than that
separate retinotopic maps in different
patches of cortex map
map loads of them
right and so there's all kinds of
transformations
and so much less is known about the
functional responses and functional
organization of auditory cortex than
visual cortex
especially in humans we're really we
really don't know a lot in fact
so there's no real answer to that other
than it's not that shocking in a way
because you see that in vision and other
domains anyway with multiple maps that
differentially represent different parts
of space
and so yeah i didn't say this but many
of those
dozen or so maps in visual cortex
have differential representation of
different parts of space
right you know some focus on the upper
visual field some on the lower visual
field
and
the whole question of like is that
really one thing or is it two
this is all now getting into the kind of
cutting hedge ambiguous kind of state
that we don't know
okay
all right everybody clear on tonitapi
primary auditory cortex okay good
all right
the standard view from recording neurons
in primary auditory cortex in animals
monkeys ferrets are big in auditory
neuroscience
other animals
is that the receptive fields of
individual neurons in primary auditory
cortex are linear filters in the
following sense
okay so here's a spectrogram of a sound
this is just a description of the
stimulus as usual
time
frequency so it looks like it could be a
speech sound with some vowels there or
it might be something else who knows
okay
okay so that's a sound okay so now
what do
you know imagine an electrode sitting
next to a single neuron
in primary auditory cortex in say a
ferret listening to that sound
and characterizing what does that neuron
respond to
well the typical finding is that neurons
in primary auditory cortex
are what's known as spectrotemporal
receptive fields or stirfs to their
friends okay okay so what does that mean
here's an example of the receptive field
that is the response dependence of a
given auditory cell again with time on
this axis and frequency on that axis so
what kind of sound
does that
cell like
can you can you see just by looking at
this what kind of sound
like uh increasing
increasing frequency yeah
something like that right
okay here's one that also likes
increasing frequency but slower
shallower increasing frequency
okay here's one that likes decreasing
frequency now you may be wondering what
the stripes are we didn't talk about
this in visual cortex but this is a
common property that it likes this
particular set of frequencies here but
is inhibited by adjacent frequencies
okay so you also see something like that
with orientation tuning and um in
primary visual cortex
okay
um and so um yeah here these ones are
changing faster
both increasing and decreasing
so the idea is primary auditory cortex
in animals and presumably in humans
is full of a bunch of cells that are
basically spectra temporal filters like
this
they are picking out changes in
frequency over time
that happen to different degrees and at
different rates
okay and in different frequency ranges
okay
does that make sense more or less yes
quietly
like i said
how would you expect like that
oh yeah how do they figure that out yeah
i usually spend all this time talking
about the design of the experiment i
just skip straight to the answer here um
well i don't know exactly what you do
but you probably i mean this has been
like a whole thing that went on for
decades for people to get at this so i'm
guessing that somehow they got into that
general space and then they generated
stimuli that make all these different
sounds
and they just run through them and they
find for a given cell you play all these
different signs you get you go
you know etc it'll spare you more
imitations you play all these different
sounds to the animal and you record the
response of that neuron and you would
find for example that it responds much
more when you play that sound than any
of the others
yeah
does that make sense no it makes sense
but how do they ever hit on that no no
i'm just asking them
is that
are they using like a separate family
oh the red and the blue
um
how exactly they got rather than just
the simple thing with just that um how
exactly they arrived at that i'm not
totally sure
yeah
i mean there are mathematical reasons
why it makes sense to
have that whole thing rather than just a
single
stripe um
that i think are beyond the scope of
this lecture for the moment but anyway
yeah it wasn't it wasn't just a totally
arbitrary thing to try
um
those are particularly useful kind of
receptive fields for representing
the input
okay so everybody sort of clear
approximately what this idea so it's
very low level basic
just are the frequencies going up or
down and which range and how fast that's
what primary auditory cortex does
okay organized in this map this tonal
topic map
okay
so now
um okay
um so yeah think of a primary auditory
cortex is just this bank this big set of
linear filters for particular frequency
changes over time
okay so that's all based on
um data from animals from recording
individual neurons but we want to know
about humans not just because that's
what this course is about but we want to
know about humans i mean ferrets are
nice but really okay
so is that true for humans
well josh mcdermott and sam norman
hagner just published a paper a few
months ago
in which they addressed this question in
a really interesting way
so here's the logic this is a little bit
technical i'm trying to give you the
gist i hope it works give it a try
so they generated synthetically
computationally
what they call model match stimuli so
the idea is this the idea is if you
present a natural sound like a dog
barking or a person speaking or a toilet
flushing just some sound that you would
hear in life okay and then what they do
is they make a synthetic signal
that matches that sound
with respect to those stirfs i just
showed you
that is if you fed the original sound
and you fed this synthetic sound into
the stirfs you'd get the same thing in
the stirfs
okay so this is a way of saying
we're assuming that those stirfs are a
good description of what goes on in a1
so let's test that by taking a big fancy
real world sound that has meaning and
people know what it is and let's make a
control sound
that matches
the in stirf properties
okay
and let's see if we get the same
response in the brain
in that region
okay
if that model is a good description of
what that region does then you should
get a very similar response when you
give the synthetic sound and the
original sound that you recorded in the
world
okay so they tested this on a stirf like
model like this thing i just described
before
and so just to show you what these
sounds are like so here's an original
sound just recorded in the world of
somebody typing
okay okay okay that's enough right i
know it's riveting but okay so then they
run that through their sturf model they
get a sturf description and they
generate
a matched stimulus from their sturf
description and it sounds like this
pretty good
right it's kind of hard to tell them
apart
okay
sorry
enough
all right oh
okay and you can see the spectrograms
are really similar
okay so for a texturey thing like typing
it really captures the essence of what's
being hurt we're just we're just telling
you what these
control stimuli sound like okay let's
take another sound a person walking in
heels and you can see all those
verticals those are the clicks clicks
clicks have energy across lots of
different frequencies and that's what a
vertical line means it means all those
different remember this is frequency on
this axis a vertical line means energy
at lots of different frequencies
not organized in harmonics okay so it's
not pitchy okay here we go
okay
here's the stir version the control
stimulus
so oops so it captures some of it
but not all of it right it captures the
sound of each click but not the spacing
between so it's getting sort of the
local properties but not all of the
properties okay
yeah sorry how did you see
like just the frog how did they make it
i didn't tell you because it's
complicated they basically start with
pink noise or white noise or some kind
of noise they run it through their stirf
thing
they run the original sound through the
stirf thing they compare them and they
say how are we going to adjust the noise
to make it more like that and they just
iterate a lot okay
and they end up with these stimuli and
you can see just looking at it they
ended up with something that's pretty
similar in terms of the spectrogram
okay
let's listen to a person speaking here's
the original sound is that art offers a
time warp to the past as well as insight
okay now i'm learning how to turn it off
here's the synthetic version
okay now we've lost something so
everybody see how with keyboard typing
it really sounds the same the synthetic
version
with walking in heels kind of sort of at
least locally but not globally and with
speech we've just totally lost it
the stuff that you can capture with the
sturf model does not capture the full
richness of speech okay there's
something more in a speech stimulus than
you can capture with that just simple
stuff model okay let's listen to a
violin
[Music]
okay what does the sturf model do with
that
[Music]
i love that sounds like a sea lion
colony
okay anyway
so what you see is the sturf model
totally fails to capture speech and
music but it captures texturey sounds
like that
and it loses some of the you know
broader temporal scale information
okay so
um
so that's the stimuli
then you scan people listening to these
sounds okay just pop them in the scanner
and play those sounds
okay
and here's and so then what they do is
they just ask so this is again the white
outline is primary auditory cortex where
you have that frequency map mapped in a
separate experiment and just plunked
down on the brain here we're zooming in
on that part of the top of the temporal
lobe
and so what's shown here
is for each voxel they're showing the
correlation of the response of that
voxel to the original sound
and the synthetic sturvey sound
and what you see is those correlations
are really high in primary auditory
cortex
in other words primary auditory cortex
responds pretty much the same to the
original sound and the synthetic sound
it doesn't detect that difference
but as soon as you get outside of
primary auditory cortex you get
something totally different
and so that was exactly the prediction
is that model that's being tested here
is a model of how they thought primary
auditory cortex work a bank of linear
filters they test that model by
generating a new set of stimuli that are
matched for those linear filters and
they get pretty much the same response
in primary auditory cortex so check
that's a good model of primary auditory
cortex but also the blue shows you much
lower correlation out here it is not a
good model of stuff outside of auditory
cortex
so
isn't this kind of self-fulfilling in
the sense that i build my
uh sort of synthetic stim line based on
these kind of models and then i
it is except it is except the models
were all based on animal work and this
is human brains so this is a way it's
it's but that's exactly right it's a way
of saying
all this work from from animals
precisely characterizing response
properties of individual neurons which
you can do in animals and mostly not in
humans
do we think that's true of human primary
auditory cortex and yes it is does
everybody get at least the gist of that
i realize i skipped over lots of details
because i want you to get the general
picture okay
okay yeah so what what are we trying to
sort of achieve by doing this kind of a
motor transfer again i mean the
hypothesis is that
the human and the animal auditory
robotics
is the same primary auditory cortex yes
yes they're basically testing you derive
that model from the animal work
then you test then you design a test of
it which is making those synthetic
stimuli
and i left this out because actually i
don't think they've done that but
presumably if you test those stimuli
with single units and ferrets you get
the same thing you get very very similar
responses in primary auditory cortex to
the original sound and the synthetic
version of it based on the sturf model
but it's predicated on this assumption
that both them are structurally the same
well it's testing it's asking that
question it's asking that question
right because i've occasionally in here
lamented about how crappy our methods
are in human cognitive neuroscience i
mean they're fun we can do something but
we hit of all pretty fast we want to see
the actual neural code we don't have
spatial and temporal resolution at the
same time
we pretty much only get that in animals
we can pretty much only do really
careful causal tests in animals we can
pretty much only see connectivity in a
precise way and as all these things we
can do only in animals and so we need to
know
if those animal models are good models
for humans and this is a way to test it
and to pass with flying colors
okay makes sense
okay so primary auditory cortex
seems in humans that it's much like it
is in ferrets a bank of linear filters
with sturfi properties right
okay
what about everything else
after all you guys could hear the
difference between the original version
and the synthetic version of the woman
talking and the violin and if i played
to all the other stimuli of real world
sounds you could hear the differences in
many of the other ones as well so what
are you doing well there's lots of
auditory cortex beyond primary auditory
cortex
that could represent that difference and
what this is suggesting is whatever's
going on out here is doing something
really different with those sounds it is
not fooled it does not think the
synthetic thing is the same thing as the
original thing that's what the low
correlation means okay
all right
um so i'll tell you about just one
little patch of cortex out there
uh and that is
okay again
this is just for reference we've zoomed
in again on um this is a little code for
separate mapping of high low high
primary auditory cortex right there
and what the yellow bands are
is selective responses to speech
so you compare a whole bunch of speech
sounds to a whole bunch of non-speech
sounds and you get a band of activation
right below primary auditory cortex yes
i thought the separation was like
did i high low high
dad probably said it backwards that's
that would be like me but it's
okay wait wait what the hell is it
it's i'm pretty sure it's high low high
let's go back and look
i probably i might have screwed it up on
the slide or set it backwards so i'm
pretty sure it's
yeah it's high low high
okay
so the low frequency is the
greater yep yeah just like that's the
code for frequency right there
okay
but ask me those questions because i'm
very capable of getting things backwards
as you've probably already noticed
all right
so there is a band of speech selective
cortex
just outside of primary auditory cortex
in that region that we just saw responds
differently to the original sound
and the model matched synthetic sound
okay
so that's pretty cool what do i mean by
speech selective cortex
what i mean is
um i tried this this is some of our data
i tried to find you someone else's data
and i
went down a 45-minute rabbit hole trying
to find a nice slide and i just couldn't
find a good picture if i said okay screw
it i'll show you my data even though i'm
trying to no i'm not we're not the only
ones who've shown this we just have the
best data now other people had tested it
with
you know four five six conditions we
tested it with 165 sounds okay
okay so each of the so this is the
magnitude of response in that yellow
region to 165 different sounds color
coded by condition shown down here
and so what you see if you look at it is
all the top sounds
are light green and dark green
speech
notice
importantly
that the response is very similar to
english speech and foreign speech which
our subjects do not understand
so that tells us that this is not about
language
this is not about the meaning of a
sentence or syntax or any of that stuff
this is about phonemes right the
difference between a ba and a pa
which you can do on a foreign language
even if there's a few phonemes that are
different you get most of them
okay so everybody get the difference
between speech and language
amazingly the senior author of the paper
you read for last night does not
understand that difference
he published a beautiful paper
every time he comes here to speak he
talks about language language language
language
and i say eddie
have you ever presented a stimulus
that's in a foreign language it's like
oh no that'd be really interesting it's
like eddie
until you do that you don't know if
you're studying language or species like
oh yeah really interesting
and he comes back four years later
and he doesn't seem to know the
difference between language and speech
i'm like hello
anyway
he does beautiful experiments but it's
just like i don't know it's a blind spot
or it's a misuse of a word i don't know
what it is but it drives me nuts can you
tell
anyway you guys get that difference even
if eddie doesn't
um
let's look at some other things how
about all this light blue stuff there's
a lot of light blue stuff that's almost
as high oh that's music with people
singing that also has speech
the speech is slightly less intelligible
because it's singing and there's
background instrumental music so it's a
little bit lower
oh what's next we got some light purple
stuff
and some dark purple stuff okay this is
non-speech vocalizations that's stuff
like laughing and crying and sighing
okay
pretty similar to speech but not speech
it's the next highest thing but it's
well down from the speech sounds
right and then we have you know dogs
barking and geese and stuff like that
that are yet further down and then we
have all kinds of other stuff down there
sirens and toilets and
you know stuff like that yeah
is instrumental music perceived as
speech is i mean i can't make all the
colors from here
no
the instrumental music is way down in
here
yeah it's a little hard to see that
stuff up there is non-speech
vocalizations it's not it's not a
perfect slide
okay so
that's pretty strong evidence that that
band of cortex is pretty selective for
speech everybody get that
yeah so you're saying it's not that it
doesn't process like the other one so
like the violin stuff is still
yeah
right
okay good point remember when i first
showed you the fusiform face area i
showed you that time where it's like
okay faces are like this staring at dot
is like that looking at objects is like
this
right so i said okay there's a little
bit of a response to things that aren't
faces it's just much more to faces
now you guys may not have noticed this
because it went by kind of fast but when
i showed you intracranial data from the
fusiform face area in that patient who
got stimulated there and saw the
illusory faces
the intracranial data showed
zero response to things that are not
faces
so i think that that's because
functional mri
is the best we have in spatial
resolution in the human brain except
when we have intracranial data
right but it's still blurry it's blurry
because there's blood flow
and all of that right
so i would guess the same thing here
uh in fact i guess it isn't in the paper
you read because he didn't have any
non-speech sounds
but i will show you
dana's recording them right now in
children's hospital and we have some
other ones that i will show you next
time
of intracranial electrodes and they will
be even more selective than that okay
but this is pretty good already yeah
nova what should we wear
i didn't hear what the human non-vocal
oh that's um
oh that's like clapping and
footsteps and i forget what else yeah
things where you hear it and you know
that's a person but it doesn't sound at
all like speaking or speech
so you know if it was about the meaning
like could have been all about the
meaning of people could be something
telling you there's a person there deal
with it but no apparently not
okay
okay so we're not the first ones to see
this we've just tested it with more
conditions so our evidence for
selectivity is stronger than everyone
else's
given what i've told you today
can you think of a stronger way to test
this
for example suppose i was worried well
maybe the frequency composition of the
speech
is different than the non-speech after
all those are just recordings of natural
sounds in the world that we went out and
made or mostly got off the web
um
someone else made
and maybe they differ in really low
level properties and so how do we know
that that's really speech selectivity
not just selectivity for certain
frequencies or frequency changes yes you
would run it with the like mcdermott
generator bingo
absolutely everybody get that
right so then we'd know because those
are beautifully designed to match all
those
acoustic properties match the
spectrogram
right you know for all those lower level
properties
uh and mcdermott and norman hagner have
done that
and this region does not respond
strongly to the model match version so
it's not just the acoustic properties
yeah um can we also do something like
this inversion place page backwards
yes people have done that too
um it's a little bit complicated because
speech backward sounds a lot like speech
it's it's you know it's a little kind of
in the intermediate zone so it balances
many things but one it doesn't balance
all the acoustic properties right so
speech has certain onset properties i
forget how it goes but if you if you
play it backwards there's lots of
you know you've heard backwards speech
played right it's all you know um and so
the the the sturf model would respond
differently to forward and backward
speech
whereas the stiff model responds the
same
to the original and the synthetic speech
makes sense
okay
so um so yeah there's a very speech
selective patch of cortex
um
and um
it's speech selective not language
selective
and of course we want to know okay
speech speech is lots of different
things
it's what words you're saying
it's who's saying it
it's your intonation are you making a
statement or a question or what are you
emphasizing in the sentence and it's
lots of other things
and the paper you read asked that
question what's coded here about speech
yeah
um and so i made a whole bunch of slides
to explain what the paper um said
because i thought people would have
trouble with it everyone nailed it so
i'm not even gonna go through that maybe
i'll just show you one
in closing okay so one thing a few of
you got wrong
and i totally get why it didn't matter
is that here is this is one patient and
this is the bank of electrodes placed on
the surface of the brain
the red bits are the bits where you
could account for the neural responses
in terms of any of those models
intonation speaker identity sentence or
any of the interactions between those
things and so that just says that's
where the action is is those electrodes
there and that graph down here
is from um
only three different each one is a
single electron just so you get this so
this critical graph here that shows
electrode e1
that's one of those electrodes in one
patient okay an electrode is typically
two or three two millimeters on a side
it's probably listening to
a few tens of thousands of neurons
so it's one or two orders of magnitude
better than a voxel with functional mri
but it's still averaging over lots of
neurons
not a single nerve the questions
okay okay
what is the differential condition but
it's average to feel like
yeah yeah that was a response of one
electrode uh listening to male and
female i forget which is which right
um but other than that you guys totally
nailed it and notice how precise and
specific and
fascinatingly separated the responses of
those electrodes are segregated for
pitch contour or speaker identity or
what sentence was being spoken right
those things seem to be segregated
spatially in the brain at a fine grain
whether you'd see it with functional mri
you might you might not many of you
pointed out we might have the not have
the resolution think about other methods
you might use to look for that even if
we didn't have the the resolution with a
simple binary contrast and it's 12 26
and i'm going to stop i will see you
guys on wednesday and we will talk about
music
you